[Música]
[Aplausos]
en que se parece la propia con la
maternidad
personalmente hay hubo entre estos dos
mundos y hoy me gustaría analizarlo
la filantropía es un mundo donde te
ayuda a encontrar un propósito de vida
igual que la maternidad es una forma de
trascender impactar tu vida por otro
lado la filántropa y la maternidad
también ayudan a la mejora de un entorno
social que posiblemente heredarás a tus
hijos y de esa causa también se puede
relacionar toda la filantropía y la
maternidad se relacionan en una cosa muy
concreta que es dar tienes que dar y dar
y dar y seguir dando con convicción con
entereza con compromiso es una cosa que
no puede parar y tiene que seguir
siempre
esta no es una invitación a que te unas
a una causa esta charla es para que
encuentres tu causa para que te llenes
de ella para que la defiendas con pasión
y todo mundo nos ha dicho que hay que
poner un granito de arena pero granito
de arena como si fuera poca cosa como
decir un poco esfuerzo sin embargo
sabemos que todo lo que vale la pena en
la vida lleva trabajo y con esto mucha
responsabilidad entonces poner un
granito de arena puede funcionar porque
hace el primer paso y está bien pero
viene el que sigue y el que sigue y el
que sigue y hay que emprender este
camino de poder caminar
yo creo que está mal planteado de cómo
lo miramos dejamos la filantropía a un
lado diciendo como no me toca tengo
millones de cosas que hacer cada quien
vive su propio mundo sin embargo qué
pasaría si cambiáramos la óptica con la
que miramos qué pasaría si nos
pusiéramos estos lentes y miráramos todo
a través de la gratitud de todo lo que
la vida ya nos dio de que hoy estamos
vivos hoy estamos aquí hoy estamos con
ganas de poder hacer todos los que
estamos aquí tenemos mucho que aportar
solo es cuestión de cambiar el enfoque
para transformar el mundo es muy fácil
necesitamos dos cosas la primera tener
una causa que realmente te molesta algo
que te choque algo que te cheque algo
que te guste algo que te apasione algo
que no pueda seguir viviendo con ello
algo que digas que no no puedo más tengo
que hacerlo porque si no nadie más lo va
a ser y dos que estés lleno que esté
lleno de ti que se esté sostenga tu
verdad que nadie más lo llene que no
seas tú porque tú eres necesario en este
universo y tu existencia hoy es
necesaria para poder estar aquí
si tenemos estas dos cosas podemos
encontrar un poco de equilibrio en lo
que somos y es importante y la vida nos
reta a tener equilibrio sin embargo para
eso lo vamos a poder seguir descubriendo
les quiero contar un poco de cómo puedes
encontrar tu causa cómo puedes hacer que
esto que hoy hice es posible yo ayudo
siempre hay posibilidad de ayudar
siempre hay un inverso que puedes ayudar
pero vamos a les quiero compartir algo
muy personal
y esto es lo que siento
resulta que tenga un primo hermano más
hermano que primo que se llama adrián
entonces tengo un recuerdo que hoy les
quiero compartir que es estos recuerdos
que tengo muy claro de cuando era
chiquita yo pasé mucho tiempo y
estábamos el es dos años mayor que yo y
estábamos en un arenero jugando en un
parque cuando de repente
[Música]
sentaditos en la arena llega un niño de
estos molestón es que siempre nos
encontramos y coge un puño de arena y se
lo echa en la carga y coge otro puño de
arena y se lo echa en los ojos y cogió
otro puño de arena y adrián sin poder
hacer nada estaba sentado paralizado
resignado cuando el repente yo sentía
algo aquí que dije esto no puede ser y
me lance es hora que el niño y le metió
una mordida que le clavé todos los
dientes aún aquellos dientes que no me
salían y lo mordí con todas mis fuerzas
diciendo así no por defender a adrián
total en niños de fue berreando con su
mamá a decir que una niña le había
mordido la cara peor que una leona y
llega con una del brazo con su mamá
verdaderamente enojada buscando a la
mamá de la niña que había mordido como
perro a su hijo y yo me sé chiquita
mejor esa sensación de decir
no
los adultos discutían y cuando llega mi
mamá me dicen no te preocupes muy bien
por defender a adrián todo es válido y
ahí fue descubrí mi semilla que es
muchos años después daría fruto en un
camino que aún no conocía
todo el mundo hemos encontrado este
sentir todo mundo tenemos las
herramientas de un lienzo perfecto para
hacer una obra de arte con nuestra vida
tenemos una paleta de colores infinita y
así la sabemos combinar podemos ponerle
alma a esa a esa obra que no sea
simplemente para uso decorativo
necesitamos crear estas obras de arte de
artistas verdaderos que impacten y
trasciendan el tiempo que con el tiempo
cuando ya no estemos aquí la gente se
acerque a ver realmente esta obra de
arte y las pinceladas con la luz que
pudiste crear y esto se hace siempre y
cuando tengas un propósito de
trascendencia y puedas impactar la vida
de alguien más adrián por lo que sentía
y él fue mi semilla
para hoy estar aquí
total pasa la vida todo mundo tenemos
nuestras propias retos subidas bajadas
baile vale toda mi vida
vivi grasa dios entre familia entre
amigos entre un salón de ballet lleno de
espejos lleno de barras con retos que se
pueden la mente que es tipo del cuerpo y
quién puede más y así hice muchísimas
amigas
[Música]
que fueron mi universo que hoy también
me sostienen y luego me casé con un
gigante de corazón
yo vi landeros ella era un superhéroe de
la filantropía mexicana y yo lo acompañé
a volar que cuando lo estaba acompañando
hablar de hill para qué sirvo aquí si
este universo ya funciona cuál es mi
función en un mundo que ya sirve y ahí
la respuesta es muy fácil cuando tú
entreteje estos universos cuando tú
sabes qué hacer y cuando tú conjuga sus
mundos la respuesta se da sola y
entretejen miss universos
era mi familia y adrián
con lo que me gustaba hacer que era
bailar y ahí nació el ballet teletón y
el ballet el letón ha dado frutos
increíbles ya vídeo teatros llenos con
gente de pie y ahí he puesto muchísima
energía y muchísimas ganas de encontrar
mi trascendencia en el mundo partía este
programa y ha sido muy padre la verdad
es que hemos tenido unas historias que
realmente vale la pena cortar cada una
de ellas pero
[Música]
cuando dices que tienes todas las
respuestas
la vida te vuelve a cambiar las
preguntas
y es así cuando me entero que voy a ser
mamá de trillizos y supones que te va a
consumir algo de tiempo y ya tienes un
show listo para continuar y tienes que
ponerle todas las ganas y no puedes
prescindir de ninguna pista pero cuando
eres mamá
te tienes que hacer mamá en la extensión
de la palabra
es como si te entregaran una caja tienda
de tesoros de joyas preciosas que lo
único que puedes hacer es preservar su
brillo y es abrazar los días un poco
olvidarte de ti hay veces en la
maternidad te tienes que olvidar de ti y
es bien difícil no puedes seguir andando
y no puedes seguir porque el brillo está
en ellos sin embargo es tu misión más
importante preservar la luz y la pureza
de las joyas preciosas que son sus tres
corazones
total sigue pero el show debe de
continuar ahora con más pistas y las
mismas 24 horas
entonces
y te tienes que partir no hay más y es
como los dedos de una mano no cada quien
tenemos una mano y cada quien tenemos
cinco dedos y esos cinco dedos cada
quincena de diferentes cosas profesión
amigos familia espiritualidad los demás
pero si no tienes este último de los
demás a quién puede beneficiar tu vida
nos quedamos un poco huecos no te puede
faltar una causa social en el abanico de
tu vida necesitas poner su foco en ello
para que entonces tu vida pueda
trascender y puede estar completa
alcanzando más sentido
les quiero contar cada uno de estos
cinco dedos y de cómo podemos encontrar
en la misión o nuestra causa o lo que
nos apasiona o cómo podemos
inhalar y llenarnos de vida y luego
exhalar leerlo en la causa
tenemos que estar completos nosotros
para que entonces podamos completar a
los demás y aquí va la primera
encuentre algo que te choca algo que te
voltea te haga voltear para el otro lado
algo que te haga poner la piel de
gallina algo que digas uff no lo puedo
ni ver no me cuentes no me digas no
tengo tiempo eso es lo que necesitamos
encontrar que te hace escribir sí y ahí
puede ser que algo brinque 2 pregúntate
que sabes hacer
y combínalo con que sabes sentir y ahi
entreteje tus universos
hay muchas cosas que necesitamos dar hay
muchas necesidades que no porque todo
sea tan grande no podemos dar y empezar
a dar nuestro camino pregúntate que
sabes hacer si sabes del que estoy
segura que la vida te va a regalar el
como q3 ponte a sembrar el que mira el
del viento no siembra un pieza empieza
ya a ponte a trabajar nunca va a ser el
tiempo perfecto para que todo se alinea
y entonces se pueda dar la situación de
empezar a colaborar con los demás
empieza con la esperanza de que todo va
a fluir y todo va a prosperar y vas a
cosechar las grandes cosas pero empieza
ya es lo más importante
vamos por el cuarto persiste este terco
hasta de oídos sordos hasta de la vista
gorda que nadie te quite las ganas de
hacer lo que tu corazón te diga haz que
la gente se sume a tu barco
haz que esta gente tenga la capacidad de
formar una tripulación que pueda remar
contra viento y marea aguas con el ego
el ego ocupa muchos lugares no te
quieras comer el pastel tú solo siempre
deja espacio que los demás rem en contra
viento y marea y entonces apropian tu
propia causa y hablen de nuestros niños
o nuestra comunidad o nuestro proyecto
como conjunto deja espacio para que los
demás remen contigo y lo más importante
es empezar a bailar ya empieza a bailar
solo
la locura se contagia haz de tu vida un
espectáculo digno de que dios lo vean
recuerda que ser rebeldes no ves lo que
esperes quedar that a lo que lo
inesperado comprate que eres lo
suficientemente loco para poder cambiar
este mundo hay que ser rebeldes hay que
construir esta utopía de que si se puede
hacer las cosas estamos en un mundo que
lo requiere poner a prueba la anchura de
nuestro corazón poner a prueba la
anchura de nuestras manos y volcar no
está en ello en un ya tenemos el
privilegio que la vida nos dio para
poder seguir dando
creo que hoy en día la esperanza no
puede ser nuestra única estrategia todo
lo contrario tenemos que volcarnos a
construir castillos del eterno porque
ahí radica nuestra verdadera fortaleza
no hay cosa más valiosa que un ser
humano generoso recuerda que lo más
importante de todo es que no se queden
huérfanos de causa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]